once again tens of thousands are out on
the streets across Israel protesting
against their government here in West
Jerusalem they're outside the
president's house hoping to be heard
however the numbers are far smaller than
in previous weeks
every Saturday they gather calling this
right-wing government a threat to
democracy in the rule of law because
it's a coalition built around openly
far-right parties it's worth noting
these protests are just about Israel not
many here are talking about the
Palestinians the stalled peace process
or continued occupation although their
numbers are significant they don't
appear to represent the majority of
Israeli Society
I think right now it is a vocal minority
we don't know what the majority of
Israelis believe because the issues
we're dealing with are very complex and
the people we're seeing protesting are
people in the economic World high-tech
lawyers
journalists people who feel the threat
who understand what this means for the
change of Israel's legal regime and the
demise of Israelis of Israel's democracy
of moving on the path of Hungary and
Poland and perhaps other countries that
have moved into an uh a system of
weakening our democracy
the government's less than two months
old and therefore too early for polling
data but it would seem the majority of
the electorate still supports the
government of Benjamin Netanyahu Anita
I am supporting the changes this
government makes this country isn't
moving there are people who aren't
letting it move they must give this
government a chance to change things
I'm right wing the government should be
a right-wing one as well
even the protesters know they're in a
minority right now but they are hoping
that will change and will become more
mainstream but here that still means
Hardline conservatives the end game for
the protesters here is to force a new
election now they may well succeed in
doing that and they may well even get
rid of some of the far-right elements
that make up the current Coalition
however
if previous governments aren't anything
to go by then that hard line
conservatism will still remain Imran
Khan Al Jazeera West Jerusalem